I hate I'll show a no-go I hate fronting
and stunting pay your bills that's all I
have to say pay your phone bills Bethany
Frankel has a message for Kim Zolciak
and Kroy Biermann I mean it's drama E.T
can confirm that the former NFL pro
filed for divorce last week from The
Real Housewives of Atlanta Alum after 11
years of marriage just hours after it
came out that the pair owes 1.1 million
dollars in taxes you know sometimes Fame
and money do change people but God can
take it from you as quick as he gave it
to you now Bethany a fellow former
housewife is weighing in and she's not
holding back I heard Kim and Kroy owe a
million dollars each and it's like good
pay the IRS you gotta hey you want to
play you gotta pay the Real Housewives
of New York Alum posted that clip to
tick tock explaining that she thinks Kim
got caught up in being on the Bravo
franchise people call me a gold digger
but they just want what I have they've
always been people who seem like they're
spending more than they have he's on a
football salary she's on a Housewives
salary and they're spending like the
planes going down and the thing is you
can't spend more than you make and it's
the old Housewives model to get on the
show make no money spend spend logo logo
car car house house bankruptcy
foreclosure because you can't
keep up you're right in checks you can't
cash and it's gross the filing comes two
months after Kim and croy's home
mysteriously escaped The Auction Block
at the 11th Hour this is my favorite
room in the whole house it's called the
Hollywood room and this is actually my
girls like TV room I am obsessed with
this room at the time ET learned the
house was in foreclosure after the
couple defaulted on their 1.65 million
dollar loan I did put some bling on my
chairs you all know I love my bling the
two share six children their parents to
Croy Junior cash and twins Kaya and Kane
plus Kroy adopted Kim's now adult
daughters from a previous relationship
Brielle and Ariana from day one I've had
a connection
uh Brielle and Ariana and it's just
continued to grow E.T can confirm Croy
filed for divorce on Friday a lot has
changed the reason according to docs
obtained by E.T Croy separated from Kim
on the terms that the marriage is
irretrievably broken now a source tells
ET that people close to the couple are
in complete shock adding no one saw this
coming
Kim and Croy have always come off as
couple goals and seemed so in love
ET has reached out to Kim for comment
but back to Bethany who's been through a
messy split of her own the skinny girl
entrepreneur shared these final words
these two you know were so perfect and
we're so in love and we have all this
money and we're spending and the
Diamonds and this and the filters and
the kids and everything and then when it
goes sideways you invited us in when it
was going good and it looked like a
fairy tale well guess what we're about
we're coming out with you too so No
One's Gonna respect your privacy at this
time and I just I think I get
particularly lit when people spend what
they don't have it's like up the whole
system it's like working with the IRS
like you pay your bills
foreign